most of the pain that people experience
is purely in their own minds I think
there's an interesting one between like
burnout versus hard for me burnout is I
would Define it as my output per unit of
time decreases so I can see that that's
measurable I can say like number of
pages that I edit or the quality of the
content that I create like my output per
time like the team knows when I'm like 6
hours 7 hours into recording something
they're like I literally start like
slumping physically I just start like
slumping like I'm just not as sharp
right there's that versus emotional
burnout which I think people mislabel as
burnout when really it's just like they
don't know how to reframe reality